oh I don't know I can't answer question
like that you know you say you're
optimistic and and you know the world is
full of surprises got lord knows in 2001
we thought you know we had no enemies
the world we were on a course the only
problem seemed to be the stock market
was stock market boom seemed to be a
little bit over and look what happened
with the history the course of the
course of the world or the course of
this country at least change which
affected the course of the world and I
don't think you can be too sanguine
about what the future holds um well I
think this age will be remembered as a
time in which America really struggled
with its world leadership the United
States went into a new phase of of
economic development as its as its as
its technologies became more dominant
its population changed from became an
older population began to become an
increasingly Latino population I don't
have a quick adjective the age of what
of whatever but I think those are the
dominant theme
you